on apprend donc ce soir que le cirque du
soleil va passer à des intérêts
étrangers
gérald bonsoir donc vous avez une
confirmation l'entente est presque
conclu nous avons la confirmation d'une
source proche de guy laliberté que le
cirque du soleil est sur le point d'être
vendu que la transaction sera
officiellement probablement annoncée
lundi en début de semaine prochaine guy
laliberté donc qui vend 90 % de ses
actions et qui en concert 10% le siège
social reste à montréal c'était une
grande question parce que les créateurs
sont ici nous dit on et qui serait
hasardeux de commencer à tout rebâtir
ailleurs dans une autre ville mais les
employés du siège social n'ont pas
encore été rencontré bon et qui seront
ses nouveaux propriétaires alors ces
deux fonds un fonds américain et un
fonds chinois le fonds américain cdpj
capitole qui est un gros fonds américain
de près de 70 milliards de dollars sous
actifs présentement et fosun un fonds
chinois le plus gros de tous les fonds
d'investissements de chine et à des
sources et des médias qui avance que la
caisse de dépôt et placement du québec
auraient participé à cette transaction
également peut-être de l'ordre de 10%
des actions mais ça demeure à confirmer
alors on sait que le gouvernement
couillard a toujours insisté pour que le
siège social reste à montréal absolument
le 26 mars dernier le premier ministre
est même sorti publiquement pour
interpeller guy laliberté lui demander
de garder le siège social à montréal et
les 1400 employés il rappelait que le
gouvernement du québec et c'était rené
lévesque qui était premier ministre à
l'époque avait aidé le cirque du soleil
à prendre son envol en 1984 dernières
informations guy laliberté voulait 2
milliards de dollars pour la vente de
ses actions il somme qu'il aurait eu
moins que souhaitait en raison de la
santé financière du sol du soleil et
parce qu'il avait pas assez
d'investisseurs qui se sont présentés
pour faire une offre gadret quelque part
absolument merci beaucoup géré à les
revoir